now the arguments tonight have fired
your political passions you've still got
time to register to vote on May the 7th
you can do so online now our next
question is from Rebecca creamer
I'm a 25 year old graduate with a good
job but my generation as a whole have
got it pretty tough it cost us more than
our parents to go to uni we'll work well
into our 70s for smaller pensions and
high rents make saving for our own home
difficult if not impossible we'll be
less well off than our parents and it
feels like we're paying for other
people's mistakes if you're elected what
will you do for my generation to help us
feel optimistic about our future Rebecca
thank you very much indeed
yam would ply Kamri believes that we
need to invest in our young people
particularly in education as that is the
best route out of poverty you're right
when you say that young people today are
going to fare worse than the older
generation and it's the first time for
it for a long wire that the generation
of today is going to be worse off than
the generation before it plight camry
wants to provide free tuition fees for
students but because of austerity we are
not in a position to do that even if we
were running the welsh government we
want to keep the tuition fee subsidy
that is available for our students but
we would like students to study in will
so that we can invest that public money
into welsh universities but we would
like some courses to be made available
for free and I talked earlier on about
the need for doctors in the health
service in Wales and we believe that we
can attract more doctors by providing
free tuition for those particular skills
group of workers Youngwood Thank You ed
miliband Rebecca you speak for so many
young people right across our country so
many young people I meet who are asking
why they're paying the price of hard
times and that's what we've got to turn
around and that's what I'm going to do
if I'm your prime minister look the
first thing we've got to do is we've got
to guarantee all young people access to
a good education so you get a
high-quality apprenticeship
if you get the grades that's a guarantee
the next Labour government will make and
will also cut the tuition fee from nine
thousand to six thousand pounds because
I don't want our young people drowning
in debt when they leave University next
we've got to create good jobs for young
people
that's why we'll ban the exploitation of
zero-hours contracts and we'll say if
you do regular hours you get a regular
contract and lastly we'll build homes
again in our country 200,000 homes a
year by 2020 and get a fair deal for
young people in the private rented
sector where many young people are being
ripped off I believe in the what I call
the promise of Britain that the next
generation does better than the last I
believe we can restore it Edmund van
thank you David Camm well thank you
Rebecca for your question I think it's
absolutely crucial I think the most
important thing is to make sure there
are good jobs for people to do and
obviously in the last Parliament we've
created two million new jobs in the next
parliament we want to create two million
more good jobs for people
I think apprenticeships and universities
are vital I want our young people have
the choice of either so we're going to
have three million apprenticeships in
the next parliament but also we've
uncapped university places so who ever
wants a place can go to university in
terms of building homes I want us to
build homes that people can afford to
buy and that's what us our starter homes
are all about put it 80% of the market
price not available to foreign buyers or
investment funds but they're for British
people to buy and to own and with our
help to buy that has helped about eighty
eight thousand people onto the housing
ladder we can make that a reality for
people I know it seems odd to answer a
question for a young person about
pensions but actually it is important to
be able to look forward to security and
dignity in old age we've safeguarded the
pension because people in our country
should be able to look forward to
dignity and security at the end of a
hard working life they become a thank
you nutty Bennet well Rebecca we believe
that education is a public good and
therefore it should be paid for from
general progressive taxation far more
progressive than we have now just look
at the facts on this students on average
now a leading University with 44,000
pounds worth of debt 73% of them on
current figures will never pay that off
they're going through 30
years of their life for many people from
roughly their mid 20s to the mid 50s
anytime you earn any sort of money at
all you're going to be paying a
significant chunk of your income to a
debt that you'll never repay and it's
not like this system is actually working
on current figures again 45 P in the
pound is never going to be repaid so we
in the Green Party not only want 0
university tuition fees we also want to
pay off student loan company debts so
people don't have that weight of debt
but of course we also need changes in
housing and jobs that you can build a
life on which is why we're calling for a
minimum wage of 10 pounds an hour by
2020 Natalie Bennett thank you nick
clegg Rebecca Rebecca let me take the
issue of tuition fees head-on
I of course famously infamously couldn't
put into practice my party's policy on
tuition fees for reasons which I hope
familiar with they were introduced by
labour and actually jacked up by labour
and there was no money left but we did
did the next best thing
got the fairest deal possible and
thankfully now there are more young
people going to university than ever
before on full-time courses and there
are more young people in disadvantaged
backgrounds but if I couldn't do that
I hope I hope some fair minded folk
would at least acknowledge many of the
other things that I'm very proud I have
managed to do to give more opportunities
to create a stronger economy and a
fairer society we've talked about more
apprenticeships than ever before the
huge tax cuts which mean you pay nothing
no tax a lot on the first ten thousand
six hundred pounds you earn as of next
week a better money going to schools
through the pupil premium for
disadvantaged kids healthy meals at
lunchtime for little children at primary
school these are the things which make a
fairer future for future generations and
I'm very very proud of them thank you
little sturgeon well I'm the First
Minister of Scotland we're investing in
record number of apprenticeships more
affordable homes and helping the poorest
young people in our country stay on at
school and college but we've also kept
access to university free of tuition
fees I grew up in a working-class family
I wouldn't be standing here this First
Minister of Scotland without the free
education I had access to as a
politician now I have no right to take
that same and title away from the next
generation of young people so I will
always fight work
do whatever it takes to keep access to
university free I think it's shameful
for any politician who has benefited
from that free education to take away
from others so SNP MPs in the House of
Commons and the Scottish Parliament
anywhere else will always support the
principle but your access to education
as a young person should be based
entirely on your ability to learn and
never ever on your ability to pay
Connexus version Thank You Nigel Farage
I think there's a section of young
people in this country who are having a
fantastic time life is great they're
full of optimism they're the rich
they're the rich and they're the ones
who go to the 7% of schools or their
parents are wealthy enough to pay for
their education and they are now
dominating politics the media the arts
sport in a way I haven't seen before and
their families get richer and richer and
the gap the social inequality in Britain
grows with every single year by
abolishing grammar schools by abolishing
selective education what we did actually
was to pull up the ladder on tens of
thousands of young men and women every
year who would have done better had they
gone to a grammar school with university
education
we encourage lots of people to go to
university who actually weren't academic
and have come out with debt and would
have done better with trade and skills
and to give optimism on housing well
I've said earlier we have to build a new
house every set of minutes to cope with
migration let's cut the numbers and
let's have a brown field building
revolution